in the United States solar energy now
provides twice as many jobs as the coal
industry it's creating jobs at a much
faster pace than coal it creates jobs at
a rate 17 times faster than the overall
economy Solar is more rapidly becoming
cheaper we've been covering the
increased efficiency of the physical
solar panels for many many years and yet
solar energy still makes up only about
one percent of the total power supply in
the United States forty coal plants were
decommissioned in 2016 no new ones were
built and meanwhile the solar industry
broke tons of Records for new
installations in 2016 14 thousand
megawatts of new power from solar were
added in 2016 and this is creating many
new jobs including in construction
that's interesting because Donald Trump
claims he wants to create construction
jobs it takes about 18 months to build a
large-scale solar farm and usually local
labor is used and while solar farms are
just in specific locations solar panel
installation on the rooftops of
commercial and residential buildings are
creating jobs all over the country Cole
cannot say that about itself the solar
industry is also creating tons of
American jobs and sales and
manufacturing there's actually a report
from the solar foundation which found
that 44 out of 50 states at least
doubled their number of solar energy
jobs last year there are very few
industries that can claim that and many
of the jobs are also available to people
who might otherwise struggle to find a
decently paying job these are the people
the Donald Trump claims that he wants to
help an entry-level worker without a
college degree could possibly double
their salary within a year from 10 bucks
an hour for simple manual labor to 20
bucks an hour working within the solar
industry Trump talked about he loves the
uneducated right Andrew Andrew Andrea I
hope I'm pronouncing the last name right
lucky president and executive director
of the solar foundation told the site
coexists that quote this is just an
incredible example of the opportunities
that
just for people that need these
opportunities the most you don't see
that level of mobility within retail or
food service or hospitality or
janitorial which is where most people
who don't have higher education are
forced to look the solar industry does
provide a new option even compared to
natural gas wind and nuclear solar is
creating more jobs and notably despite
the increased presence of robots in so
many industries solar is still creating
jobs the u.s. currently produces about
39 gigawatts using solar by some
estimates by 2021 we'll be producing
about a hundred gigawatts using solar a
study found that the US has the capacity
for 200,000 gigawatts of solar energy
production that is two thousand times
the estimated 20 21 capacity government
should be helping solar energy expand
tax credits for investment requirements
to have solar power on new construction
like San Francisco's new law requiring
all new buildings to have solar panels
but we're actually going in the opposite
direction we have a president that wants
to expand dirty forms of energy like
coal that employ increasingly few people
and are terrible for the environment the
world is laughing at us the world is
laughing we can't turn back now and try
to save a dying industry when we have
new technology here that's not only
creating more jobs at this point but is
also just way greener there is no
argument for coal / solar unless part of
your argument is lining the pockets of
big political donors and maintaining the
kleptocracy and the Oleg article crony
capitalist system that's the only
argument for pushing coal / solar
because there is no data that supports
doing it and we have someone at the
highest position of power who is
actually taking it almost like as
something to brag about that he is going
to try to restore some coal jobs in West
Virginia and he is missing the forest
for the trees doesn't mean we don't care
about those west virginia workers but
they would be way better served being
retrained within the solar end
meanwhile the president's new federal
budget has a thirty one percent cut in
the Environmental Protection Agency I
yeah we're actually going to go into the
new budget tomorrow it's absolutely
insane on the bonus show today tesla's
will soon be not much more expensive
than your regular old gasoline-powered
vehicle a trump campaign chair has been
caught in a motel room with an underage
boy we will also talk about an insane
thing that is happening in my neighbor
neighborhood here in Boston as a result
of the snow locals probably can guess
what I'm going to talk about and it will
probably come as a shock to people
outside of the city of Boston because it
is insane all of that and more on
today's bonus show david pakman.com
slash membership the coupon code is
still available it's I voted 17